Mary poppins,
I can tell you that I have to look back
and see how far we've come in all
movements,
all social movements,
and every social movement faces this
massive uphill battle of being laughed
at,
scorned,
rejected,
uh,
you can look back and just be amazed at
the things humans have done to others in
the past.
So that is encouraging.
But I look at the enormity of what's a
hedge.
And that's discouraging,
but it doesn't really matter,
does it?
Because you'd never know.
You can't get to that crystal ball.
You'll never know whether you're going
to succeed or a meteor writer's going to
hit the earth and it won't matter
anyway.
So I feel that I can do is as much as I
can in this finite amount of time I
have.
And as you get older,
time goes quicker and you realize how
little you have left,
not when you're young.
It just doesn't seem to be that,
that way.
So in that small time,
I think you can do as much as you
possibly can stink to do in case it's
going to make a big difference and have
a big knock on door,
which is your.